the pioneering electric car company
Tesla has suffered a series of very
public challenges since the beginning of
this year it's high-profile CEO Elon
Musk calls this period of production
hell most of the troubles revolve around
the company's model three sedan it's the
first mid price electric car earlier
this week musk took us on a tour of his
Silicon Valley Factory this is the first
time Network cameras were allowed inside
the model 3 production line going to
look at the batteries we divided the
assembly into three parts and the middle
part is where we put the battery pack
and and motor in and so we call that
marriage Elon what's the hardest part
pre marriage marriage post marriage
right now a marriage is the hardest part
is the participant
Elon Musk relationship with outside
analysts and investors is also going
through a rough patch these days I'm
definitely under stress so if I seem
like an under stress then I'm gonna be
clear I definitely under stress in the
past month Tesla has issued a voluntary
recall of 123 thousand of its older
Model S vehicles dealt with a fatal
crash of a vehicle equipped with its
semi autonomous driving system and
suffered a downgrade of its credit
status on Wall Street the model three
still in your mind is a face in the
future of the company is it not yes
absolutely but the most important thing
on his mind these days is solving
production delays for the Tesla's new
model 3 sedan here at his massive
factory in Silicon Valley you started
saying we'll do five thousand a week
then okay that didn't work out we'll do
2,500 a week and now it's a little over
two thousand a week there's that trouble
you yeah no that's true I need to figure
out how to be better and then we can be
better if meeting goals Tesla's future
is tied to this car when musk introduced
it last summer the model three was built
as a company's first mid-price
mass-produced electric car accessible to
middle-class customers not just the
super-wealthy you said to your team
everybody get ready to meet the demand
we're gonna be in production hell yes
but you didn't expect this kind of
production hell or did you know it's
worse than I thought
why is that why is it harder what
happened we got complacent about some of
the things that we felt were our core
technology we put too much new
technology into the model three all at
once that this this should have been
staged high-tech goes in the cars but it
also builds them this is widely regarded
as one of the most robotics driven auto
assembly lines on the planet you on part
of the thing I heard about the model 3
is that there's too many robots that may
not agree you do you think so that maybe
you need more people in here working we
do in some cases the robots actually
slowed the production yes that is where
this crazy complex network of conveyor
belts and it was not working so we got
rid of that whole thing this is cool
yeah realizing it needed an overhaul
must personally took over the model 3
production line at the beginning of
April raining for really extreme levels
of precision he says he has resorted to
pulling all-nighters at the plant
I think so yeah really intense I don't
have time to go home and shower and
change side sleep here I wanted to see
words I mean it's pretty boring it's
actually cold in here too yeah I like it
cool so you have a you like it cold I
see when I catch with her
so you're just laying here yeah couch
yeah last time as you're actually step
literally on the floor cuz the couch is
too narrow yeah I was gonna say and you
know I have to say it's not even a
comfortable couch either no it's
terrible kiss is not a good couch what
is the numbers say for the last seven
days what is the number 2071 you pleased
with that yeah for the time being yeah
musk feels like all the overtime is
paying off and now he says a model three
line is back on track
and we're able to unlock some of the
critical things about holding us back
from reaching 2,000 cars a week but
since then we've continued to do 2,000
cars a week do you think that this is
sustainable
this page is sustainable yeah so
probably have I don't know a three or
four fold increase in model 3 output in
the in the second quarter but most
critics have heard predictions like
those before
a future the automaker has yet to reach
Leon you may be one of the few people to
see it because a lot of people looking
at you don't see it they're probably
people that have a lot of analysts is
that kind of look in the rearview mirror
instead of looking at the front
windscreen what do you mean by that this
is very frequently been why people have
underestimated Tesla because they would
look at Tesla's what has done in the
past and use that as proxy for what we
were able to do in the future on April
Fool's Day must mix his optimism with
dark humor on social media in the midst
of widespread concerns Tesla might
collapse he tweeted this we are sad to
report that Tesla has gone completely
and totally bankrupt so bankrupt you
can't believe it you know people are
nervous and they're worried you are
aware of that so knowing that why would
you do an April Fool's joke that you did
because there's media articles saying
that Tesla's going bankrupt yes so I
thought well I'll just do an April
Fool's joke that we did go bankrupt but
Elon that's not funny when people are
nervous
I mean it's April Fool's people should
like lighten up okay like it should be
pretty obvious I think that I'm not
going to joke about bankruptcy if I
think it's remotely real I'm feeling
pretty optimistic about what Tesla is at
this point like at this point like I
have a clear understanding of the path
out of hell and I do not until recently
have a clear understanding yama says
anyone who pre-ordered the model 3 when
it was unveiled last july should be
getting their car in about three to six
months and that's about six to nine
months later than they were promised so
listen I have to say he really is on the
case when you hear about him sleeping at
that factory go yeah sure right but I
asked employees when he wasn't around he
actually does sleep in that room and I
said but why are you doing this it's not
like you're out there you know painting
a car or running a machine he said
because I can solve the problems in real
time I look at that board I can see
where a problem is and go and make the
correction and go check it out myself so
no one's very serious what I like
hearing about him is he's showing us him
making his mistakes in real time trying
to fix them tweaking we never get to
look inside the clock works while you
know what he says what he's learning
about automation matters for him who
knows if it'll help with the car but
it's a crucial thing happening to all
business is learning that you can over
automate and to watch that happening in
real time and also fascinating to let us
in when he knows he's under the gun when
he knows that people are complaining he
says sure come on in he's very calm very
confident and very he's very
matter-of-fact he's very bad effect in
the way he speaks but I just think he's
he's terrific and on the case yeah old
and create as he thinks outside the box
Nora we like that well more of him and a
club that's right yes